and the weather's not very good but I'm
thinking about all the time the language
so on my way over there I listen I'm
listening to my polish history in Polish
and words are going into my head and I
was thinking you know language learning
is all about words
if I'm on link I see a word I click on
it I save it to my database I throw it
into my brain I don't worry about it if
I'm listening I hear words I throw them
into my brain I don't worry about them I
don't worry about the words I don't
remember I know that in time these words
are somehow like magic gonna become
known because I've heard them and seen
them in so many different contexts that
they all become part of words that I at
first recognize and understand and
eventually I'm gonna be able to use them
so I just grab the words throw them in
my brain don't worry about them and
that's the secret to successful language
learning and now I gotta go and get my
car